we start with the archbishop of
canterbury who is to miss the queen's
platinum jubilee service at saint paul's
cathedral on friday after testing
positive today for covert 19. lambeth
palath say the archbishop has also been
suffering from mild pneumonia since last
week
while we understand justin welby is now
resting at home having cancelled all his
engagements for this week and the
archbishop of york will now take the
sermon at friday's service instead
a beacon that the archbishop was due to
light on thursday evening as part of the
jubilee celebrations will now be lit at
lambeth palace on his behalf
uh let's get more on this we can speak
to our correspondent aisha sahid who has
been following events
foreign palace in central london aisha
what more can you tell us
well the archbishop of canterbury has
said that he's deeply saddened to be
missing out on these platinum jubilee
celebrations while he focuses on his
recovery from both covid and pneumonia
now it was the pneumonia that came first
he was diagnosed with a mild case last
week on thursday but under medical
advice he was he did continue work
albeit on a reduced schedule but then
over the weekend he developed coveted
symptoms and that positive cover test
came in earlier today now the archbishop
of canterbury was due to deliver a
sermon during one of the friday events
one of the largest jubilee events the
service of thanksgiving at st paul's
cathedral that will now be delivered by
the archbishop of york instead and like
you said he was also due to light a
beacon here at lambeth palace on
thursday that will now be lit on the
archbishop's behalf and
we've had some words through from the
archbishop of canterbury he's released a
statement
in which he has said i am deeply
saddened to be missing the historic
celebration of her majesty the queen's
platinum jubilee however i will be
praying for the queen and giving thanks
for her extraordinary 70 years of
service to us all i hope this joyful
occasion will inspire us with the
queen's profound commitment to fostering
unity and peace among all people and to
promoting care for the natural world
that god has given us and as we continue
to live with coronavirus i pray too for
all those who are still suffering and
everyone who continues to mourn loved
ones they have lost during the pandemic
may you each know the love and comfort
of god so the archbishop of canterbury
will be absent from the queen's uh
platinum jubilee service
i sure thank you ashes ahead with the
latest there from lambeth palace